hello i'm brian rubin and i am here with
tom and nina and we are going to talk
about the weirdest stories that did me
what did nutella let's try that one
again
sorry did me
didn't he did me you know didn't he
hi i'm brian and i'm here with tom and
nina to talk about the weirdest stories
that disney could make into a movie next
uh this was something that i thought a
lot about
because i'm a big fan of disney movies
we're all fans of disney movies to
varying degrees
and disney has adopted some weird stuff
like everyone kind of
thinks about the disney princesses and
the fairy tales and
that's where everyone's mind goes first
but they've also adapted some strange
things like the hunchback of notre dame
a story in which
the lead characters die doesn't happen
in the movie
pocahontas which is actual history
um and did not involve a friendly
raccoon and hummingbird pal
oh you don't know that much more
smallpox than that actually
much more smallpox at least 50 percent
more smallpox
treasure planet that's treasure island
but in space
um so from my opinion never made the
connection until just now
one i think is a good idea and the other
i think is a bad idea but i
i like i like the name so much so the
first idea is um gulliver's travels
i think that it would be good for disney
to adapt galva's travels which is
a famous um novel i guess like a proto
novel in a way written by jonathan swift
the famous ceterist
um and basically he uses gulliver's
travels to
um make fun of and point out the flaws
in english
imperial society and things like that
but there have been adaptations
down the road that have had very little
to do with that original
satirical intention like say
the jack black uh version that is
exactly what i was thinking of
yeah which stars emily blunt and she had
to turn down black widow to do colorful
strap
so that's why skeleton hanson is a black
widow that is as far as i know it's a
fact
that hurts my heart but so in in
gulliver's travels you've got this guy
gulliver and he just kind of goes around
traveling and he goes to lilliput and he
meets all the teeny tiny lilliputians
and then he goes to
other places with names that are hard to
pronounce i'm not going to try but then
he sees very very big people and then he
goes to a place where people live in the
clouds and he goes to a place where
people are actually horses
um and so i feel like disney could
really do a lot where they just kind of
take that framework
and do something different with it right
like treasure planet is treasure island
in space
you could do the same thing with
gulliver's travels set it in space set
it in a
complete fabricated world that's just a
fantasy world with different places and
different characters that isn't
so you know keyed into those specific
things but anyway gulliver's travel
seems like one of those things that
could work would you want it to maintain
the kind of satirical tone
because like we're talking about
jonathan swift right who wrote this book
he also wrote a modest proposal
where he advocated for eating babies
which is something i think that maybe we
should still consider
um but anyway go on yes you definitely
want that on it's really more pixar
territory though yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah they've got the pathos for
it no but i mean
um but like swift was a biting satirist
and so would you want you know a disney
adaptation of that to maintain that in a
cliff clever pixary kind of way would
you want it to be a little more fun
i think asking disney to effectively
satire
uh the real world might be asking a lot
but sure i mean wall-e is a pretty good
satire
right consumerist culture exactly
it's doable yeah i don't know how they
do it and i don't know the right
creative team right
it's got to be it's a very it's a tough
needle to thread but i think
that considering you know if we're
talking about disney
wanting to kind of work on something
that's really recognizable and also
something that's
still very much a blank canvas yeah like
no one's going to go see a gulliver's
travels movie
that disney puts out in 2025 and be like
hey where's the horse people
right red gulliver's travels and also
there hasn't been like a successful film
adaptation
i mean the jackpot is largely forgotten
there was a tv series with ted danson
that also no one remembers yeah
so what i'm saying is like it's kind of
like a great gatsby conundrum more like
there just hasn't been a good one yet
or but then so i think i think bug but
yeah i think that there's enough that
they could do with it that they could
stay
satirical but still tell a pretty good
disney style
yeah story so i think that i would
definitely see a disney gulliver's
travel
my other pick was um adapting merchant
of venice but calling it merchant of
venus
and they're aliens and that's it that's
as far as i got with it
shakespeare in space love it don't write
a single other word that is
yeah that came out of the barrel purpose
someone
write this man a giant check and get
this movie greenlit now
it's mine i own it merchant of venus
coming to a fighter near you
i bet if i google that i definitely
won't see anyone else who's made that
joke before no
it's my original life so original yeah
nailed it
got it out of the gate yeah so
tom what about you what what what's the
weirdest story that you think disney
should adapt next
okay i have three ideas because as far
as i can tell disney
uh they they have three separate uh
things that
make them money right now like once you
set aside star wars and marvels
uh like in terms of disney stories you
can either do
a uh a sequel to a cartoon that already
made money right
right uh you can do like a
quasi-respectful
uh appropriation of a cultural story
uh that you have music set through sure
or you can do a live action uh origin
story of a villain a lot wicked
right okay so my first idea
uh we could do hercules too or if you
follow me herc
tulies love it
i love it not enough movies do that
not enough it's really good too no i
know in the middle of a word
everybody should be such a clever gag
it's hilarious
every time sometimes i wake up in the
middle of the night throwing up from how
funny it is
when people use it too in the title of
their thing
so perfect uh whatever you see a doctor
i'm not a well man so
what happens in hercules is we follow
hercules from from the front and he's
married to megura and we follow their
marriage through like the actual
mythological story that the original
story follows
uh wherein uh hera hercules is like kind
of stepmom i guess like the the goddess
uh realizes that she's not actually
hercules mom
so she drives him crazy and then he
murders
megura and his children that's how you
get butts in seats
which i think will like i think it could
make for some great musical numbers like
yeah
yeah like bless myself hurricanes oh my
god
and then they cry and like pain and
panic or you've got the uh
bobcat goldthwait character and the yeah
the max headroom and they're like
they're just
there it's never too early to introduce
young children to devastating greek
myths that's all i'm saying
you're not wrong right i'm right which
is what so then we
so then we get to follow hercules
through the through like the the rest of
the story what's really cool about this
is hercules is kind of his own bad guy
at this point so yeah he's gonna cut
james woods out of the
equation yeah and then i'm fine with
that yeah
i don't need him i don't know if you
guys the way that hercules dies in the
story is
uh somebody gets tricked into putting a
poisoned shirt on him
right and it hurts so bad that he burns
himself to death
he throws himself on a pie classic and
then uh
and then burns himself to death that's
how most disney movies should end
yeah i'm glad that you said that
my second idea for like an original
story an original cartoon would be uh
the aztec myth
of uh quetzalcoatl oh jesus christ
the serpent god of the wind
i've got like kind of this whole plan
for this like that i think it'd be kind
of fun where he's like uh
he's already a god but he like he wants
to be a star right like
yeah like hollywood kind of a situation
because i don't know if you know this
but like in the original story what
happens
is that uh he he gets drunk and then
hooks up with his sister
and then gets so embarrassed that he
burns himself to death
uh this is a bit of an epidemic
yeah yeah the self uh self
implication is self immolation thank you
yeah right we could kind of ignore a lot
of that
yeah you know like disney stories always
change stuff
yeah uh so like instead he's you know
he's a god he wants to be a star and
that's exciting that he uh
and then he kind of goes up against um
like maybe another guy that would like
sort of make up like just to not be too
culturally insensitive but we just kind
of create a bad yeah yeah
yeah whole cloth you know and yeah he's
like you'll never be a star
and then like uh quetzalcoatl has like a
uh i don't know i was thinking like an
armadillo buddy i'm not really up to
date on disneyland i don't know how many
of the animal friends
i don't think we've seen an armadillo so
i think we can roll with that
was the creature in raya and the last
dragon technically in armadillo it's
like kind of a large
not quite a normal well don't worry
about it don't worry okay what was it
was it voiced by like a
slightly out of work 90s comedian no
that was a big part of the plan too if
we could get like andy dick to come in
and voice that he's due for a comeback
yeah
yeah i think that'd be really fun
so you know in the hurdles and there's
there's there's uh
yeah there's barriers to his success but
in the end uh
kessel cowada uh gets drunk and hooks up
with his sister and converts himself to
death so
that's my yeah
great my final idea okay and this one's
really quick and i apologize because
i've been talking for a while but
uh my last video for a disney movie i
know that we've been doing like all of
these live action uh
villain origin stories like we did
maleficent we did we did cruella
but i feel like we don't have enough
um of those for for young men
who are like maybe feeling a little bit
alienated from society and stuff sure so
i put
i actually i do have a vision for this
one and i'm just going to send that to
you right quick
just let me know what you think oh i
like it
and this way we could like really tell
like the origin story of this character
who eventually
uh burned to death good
good all right so nina oh wow
i have i don't i don't have time to get
into that
into that origin story we can skip my
whole thing
no i i love it give this one to nina
so uh you know there's some disney
movies about uh
a young girl wanting to marry handsome
prince and as
brian as you mentioned there are some
disney stories based on on real
historical lore and i want to combine
those two
uh inspired by a recent actual musical
that i
actually do want to see um that is
currently
playing in both london and soon to be
new york and i want to bring
uh the story of henry viii and all six
of his wives to
a disney animated film i think most
people are familiar
with uh with henry viii and the fact
that he really
so you know a lot of people are like he
loved killing his wives he only killed
two of them and there were
six so that's only a third i learned a
rhyme
do you know the rhyme of course i do
divorced beheaded died
divorced beheaded survived yeah
um i may have gotten that as a quiz oh
answer multiple times
in my life um so i i really love the
tudors because they were just
stinky hot messes who slept around and
were really
gross and they were all wildly
self-important
and especially uh henry was like his
father uh kind of at the end of the war
of the roses just kind of
showed up and was like i'll be king and
was pretty unpopular as a result and
then
henry wasn't supposed to be king because
his older brother arthur was supposed to
be king and then arthur
died so all of a sudden henry was like
well no one liked my father
my brother died and he became king
he first married you know captain of
aragon and that was a
political marriage but they were
together a long time he probably did
like her
and then he stopped liking her when she
got old and couldn't have kids anymore
because it was a really fun time to be a
woman
so he started trying to seduce anne
boleyn
who would eventually become a second
wife my favorite and i'm sure that the
commenters will
come for me or they won't because no one
cares about henry no one watching this
cares at all about ambulance
anne of green gables any of the wives
well there were two anne's you're close
so yeah so ann bolin shows up and he's
like oh be my mistress and she's like no
i must protect my virtue smart move and
he pursues her for like seven plus years
while he goes through a the world's
longest divorce and b
starts a new church just so he can get
divorced because catherine of aragon
refuses
to let him leave do you have a question
tom
yeah do we have a voice cast in mind
well not jonathan reese myers i've been
burned by that before
i don't know maybe maybe we can get like
a paul giamatti to put on a british
accent and be henry oh
man because the thing is no there's no
one alive who can do the full henry
performance because
thomas i think you're aware henry gets
ignored he starts out as a pretty
handsome prince and then he gets
enormously obese he has a like a leg
wound that won't heal from a jousting
accident and he just crashes his horse
yeah and he's drunk
all the time so what you're saying is
this is fun for the whole family
yeah and it only gets better so he
marries anne boleyn within three months
he's like i hate her too
and he kills her and he chops her head
off um he accuses her of all sorts of
demented crimes let's rapid fire the
other
four james seymour was the smartest wife
because she died before she could piss
him off so she was his favorite
uh he is buried next to her because she
gave him a son and immediately peaced
out
smart and the second smartest because
when he decided that she was an
uggo and he didn't like her and tried to
get the marriage and nulled
she said okay and he paid her handsomely
and she ended up outliving him
uh catherine howard was 15 years old and
saddled with a
husband three times her age who smelled
and maybe wasn't exactly
a virile anymore so she cheated on him
with one of his coordinates and he cut
her head off too
catherine parr almost got executed
because she was reading some books he
didn't like but luckily he died first
wasn't it the was it the toilet guy
that she cheated on him with was the
toilet guy he might have been like the
the officer of the bed chamber or
something who like what's a toilet guy
tom
well he had like they used to have guys
just for toilets yeah
yeah like you're out there yeah i mean
like you're imagine you're a giant man
with like a [ __ ] disgusting leg and uh
everything i'm imagining like old hair
yeah
yes i'm there and then you go to the
bathroom
and like when i say bathroom i'm being
very generous it's a hole in a different
it's either that or it's a pot
in your room it's just like hanging out
there waiting for you to use it
yeah okay there you go it was one of his
offices or the bed chamber you are
correct
what did the guy go down uh he
was the toilet what in the toilet no
what did the toilet guy do in the toilet
by the way his name was thomas culpepper
just he has a name
what did thomas culpepper do in with
or around the toilet he
emptied chamber pots i believe am i
correct time and i think i think he also
helped i think they were responsible for
like helping the king
because there's a lot of violence we're
talking about
right renaissance medieval yeah one of
those periods in england yeah we're
talking about disney movies but somehow
well when you say toilet guy and
especially when it comes to a disney
movie right let's not forget beast's
enchanted castle
i'm saying that's paul gmail he might be
a guy
into whom henry
uses the toilet i don't know are you
talking about a beauty and the beast
situation oh
yeah you mean he's an anthropomorphic
toilet i can
that's what i need to know yes what's a
toilet guy well and this is
that makes it even better when he has an
affair with the queen that he's yeah i'm
just imagining like a henry viii
like a court where all of the furniture
is alive and sentient and it's all just
like quiet
and like they're all just staring at the
ground because of the things that
they've seen they're
not horrified if one of them takes like
says a word out of turn he just throws
it right out the window and destroys it
and murders oh yeah
yeah yeah how do you cut the head off of
a teapot yeah yeah he'll figure it out
he was a crafty dude yeah oh this sounds
like a great disney movie
look i think it would be just absolutely
unhinged and i
i i am the only person asking for this
but i'm
humbly asking for it yeah nina
tom can you pitch three disney songs
based on the uh
the the life and also uh who writes are
we doing like alan mankin or do we want
to do like a later days disney thing
no i i totally want alan menken thank
you for bringing his name into it i love
him
um i mean maybe i want steven sondheim
to consult
because maybe we need that that edge and
all those dissonant notes
but we're not doing like sting or yeah i
think anne of cleves
uh would be like i'm not that ugly
written mostly by steven sondheim i'm
not that ugly i promise
i can already hear it yeah yeah um
catherine parker
thank god thank god he died second wife
number six
yeah and uh anne boleyn
it's not my fault i couldn't have a son
you weirdo
that's really nice yeah those are great
thank you
anyway those are my songs that's my
pitch i expect
a call from someone with the last name
disney within the hour
can i can i sit can i loop back briefly
to
to tom's toilet guy but yeah i mean
well we could talk more about toilet i
was just gonna say i mean after
hercules right it's hercules
there's the next night bye thanks for
watching
please hit like and subscribe so you
don't miss a single video